les recherches continuent au zaïre après
la disparition mystérieuse de philippe
de dieuleveult et de ses compagnons nous
avons reçu aujourd'hui les dernières
images filmées sur le fleuve zaïre du
groupe d'amis qui tentent l aventure aux
côtés de philippe de dieuleveult images
qui démontre la difficulté de
l'entreprise
commentaire de bruno dresse ses images
les toutes dernières ont été tournées la
veille du jour où les sept hommes ont
disparu
ici à quelques kilomètres des rapides
d'inga ils sont déjà dans une partie du
fleuve zaïre où personne n'est jamais
parlé
les passagers des deux bateaux sont
casqués ils ont revêtu leurs gilets de
sauvetage le courant est très puissant à
cet endroit le fleuve zaïre commencent à
se rétrécir son débit s'accélère
il atteint 43 mille mètres cubes d'eau à
la seconde sol l'amazone et plus
puissant
le moteur des rafts de tourner à plein
régime il faut essayer d'éviter les
rochers éviter de prendre trop de
vitesse
c'est alain angelini qui pilote les
passagers philippe de dieuleveult qui a
tourné ces images
lucien blocs mann's françois laurens aux
gens lui dans blard s'accrochent ils ne
peuvent rien faire d'autre maintenant
c'est le fleuve qui commande
toute la journée d'aujourd'hui les
forces aéroportées zaïroise ont exploré
la région
ils n'ont retrouvé aucune trace des cet
homme là bas on commence à être très
inquiet